because for me like i've i've tried to
focus less on the reading and just
pure conversational for me yeah um
and actually one thing that's really
helped with that is
um not watching anime actually but uh
watching yeah but watching virtual
youtubers so i've like
i've like really gotten into watching
virtual youtubers the past few months
yeah
who are you into um asakoko is probably
my favorite one
at the time of right now she just had a
3d debut i'm i'm sounding like a total
[ __ ] degenerative is that the one you
like symptoms
yeah we i saw that that's all over
twitter
i was very drunk at the time and i saw
she was like
she was having like a first 3d debut and
i'm like i'll just [ __ ]
throw like 30 bucks whatever yeah and
then like as soon as i did
like my twitter notification just like
that [ __ ] exploded
over this youtuber imagine getting
caught simping but over a virtual
youtuber
because like it's actually really helped
my japanese way more than watching anime
because with watching anime like i don't
know what the anime watching experience
has been for you connor
since you've started learning but for me
i found it a lot more
difficult to watch anime now that i'm
learning japanese because
you know when you like read the
subtitles yeah and then you kind of
understand what's going on
so you want to like try to listen in to
what's what's being said
but but because you do that you kind of
just miss
what's what's on the subtitles yeah
that's like been my anime watching
experience recently
and well i imagine joey's just on his
throne here being like yes
tell me more about your struggles what
are these subtitles you speak
okay one thing that i noticed that bugs
me is that now that i know like uh
i'd say like a very basic amount right
very minimal like
not not enough to watch an episode and
be like yep i understand that but enough
to like get some sentences right
is that when i read the subtitles and
obviously because in japanese
sometimes the the subject at the end of
the sentence in english right yeah
the start japanese so sometimes you'll
see a subtitle
that comes with the other half of the
sentence so you're hearing
the sentence that's gonna come up yeah
and it's like it was like jonathan
joestar
i was just like your next line is gonna
be
yeah and it kind of messes with you and
then also
like just watching any hentai it's
really
it's really frustrating because i'm more
like i realize like two minutes in i'm
starting to be like okay what are they
saying
oh yum at all kimo chi means good
okay yeah i guess i guess though it
makes sense
to like watch v tubers though to like
learn japanese because like
you know this is these are real people
no exactly well like speaking right they
just look like anime but like
their mannerisms and their phrasing even
though you know they might be playing
like a character right yeah it's still
like a real person because
it feels like they're having an actual
conversation because you know like
watching watching an anime and hear a
conversation you know you're like
no what i've never i've never seen a
real conversation this isn't a real
conversation that's happening right now
yeah
i'm i'm like zoning most of it out
whereas when i'm watching a youtuber
it feels like a genuine like a japanese
conversation like you're actually
hearing a story the way like any any
person you talk to japan you talk like
yeah yeah so it's been like way more
useful for me in learning japanese than
it has been watching anime
um also because i guess like with
vtubers again they're like real people
right so like
the the speed that they talk at as well
is very real
yeah it's like not like overly
accentuated so it actually makes more
sense to like get used to that kind of
speech
speed then like like
no one no one talks like that right no
because you know like
it's it's like the anime voice acting
voice yeah you know what i mean which is
which is not how real people talk like
and
this is true when like i'd say dub as
well you know you hear like a dub
voice actor or like a a dub performance
and you're like this this isn't how real
people talk this isn't how
yeah yeah
yeah yeah so it's like it's it's more
like watching a live streamer so
it's been like i'm not going to say
that's i'm not going to say that's the
only reason i've been into youtubers but
uh
it's actually if you're trying to learn
japanese i'd say youtubing
is much more useful than learning it's
educational i swear
and watching anime because watching
anime now for me has
become a lot harder and you get the joy
of finding that one video you
see him yeah you're like oh yeah that's
my one